footballer Gareth Bale the Welsh
International is retiring from
International Football he has literally
just announced this in the last couple
of minutes on social media I'll read you
his statement Gareth Bale says after
careful and thoughtful consideration I
announced my immediate retirement from
club and International Football I feel
incredibly fortunate to have realized my
dream of playing the sport I love it has
truly given me some of the best moments
of my life
the highest of highs over 17 Seasons
that will be impossible to replicate no
matter what the next chapter has in
store for me for my very first touch at
Southampton to my last with lafc and
everything in between shaped a club
career that I have an immense pride and
gratitude for playing for and captaining
my country 111 times has truly been a
dream come true to show my gratitude to
all of those that have played their part
along this journey feels like an
impossibility I feel indebted to many
people for helping to change my life and
shape my career in a way I could never I
could have ever dreamed of when I first
started out at nine years old to my
previous Club Southampton Tottenham Real
Madrid and finally lafc all of my
previous managers and coaches backroom
staff teammates all the dedicated fans
my agents my amazing friends and family
the impact you have had is immeasurable
my parents and my sister without your
dedication those early days without such
a strong Foundation I wouldn't be
writing this statement right now say
thank you for putting me on this path
and for your unwavering support my wife
and my children your love and support
has carried me through right beside me
for all the highs and lows keeping me
grounded along the way you inspire me to
be better and to make you proud so I
move on with anticipation to the next
stage of my life and a time of change
and transition and opportunity for a new
adventure so that is Gareth Bale
retiring from club and International
Football Bringing Down the curtain on a
remarkable career there have been some
question as to whether Gareth Bale would
retire from International Football after
Wales crashed out of the World Cup in
Qatar but today he has gone a step
further and announced his retirement
from club and International Football
will have much more reaction to that
breaking news story coming up on the
program here on Sky News Gareth Bale
retiring from club and International
Football